some games are timeless and res is one
of them set in a cyberspace landscape
riddled with bugs you guide your tiny
figure on a quest to awaken the
mysterious being lying dormant within it
to get to her you must shoot the rewards
of Technicolor swirling viruses that lob
projectiles and try to block your path
but it's not the narrative that makes
this game incomparable rez is a rail
shooter on paper at a heart-pounding
synaesthesia Joyride in practice to
navigate res you need only concern
yourself with aiming and shooting as you
remain on Rails moving at a set speed at
all times while holding down the X
button you use the left stick or in VR
the headsets motion tracking to
highlight the enemy or enemies with a
targeting reticle then release the
button to fire your shot and this isn't
as simple as it sounds given enemies
come flying at you from every direction
all at once and that's not even counting
the additional projectiles they toss
your way and shooting sounds are
replaced with claps and beats and
successfully destroying enemies results
in a flood of musical tones
occasionally you'll find clusters of
bright white and blue pixels that allow
you to charge up collect enough of these
and you take on a new more powerful form
additionally you'll charge up your
overdrive a powerful attack that can
clear the screen of enemies in seconds
this comes especially handy during boss
encounters while rushing bosses you must
locate and target the core object of an
undulating vibrating cluster of tiles
and life in order to dismantle one area
of this cyberspace prison these are the
most complex and challenging sections of
rez and often include multiple stages
these boss battles are also a visual
treat and with rez infinite upgraded
graphics it feels more like attending a
rave in Tron than a fight
and then there's area X area X removes
the rails and sets you off into space
allowing you to fly in any direction you
wish and doing this res infinite grants
you more power in manipulating your
space you can fly closer to or away from
enemies skirt around giant structures
shimmering in the surrounding darkness
or simply fly around in circles and let
the beat play out around you you can
maneuver around the space in a way that
lines up enemies and objects exactly how
you want them that unleash a torrent of
tones following your own rhythm I played
through area X several times and never
found the same rhythm twice but playing
the game in VR places res and what feels
like its final form in the original
areas you can look up down and behind
you for a greater view of the world you
inhabit
this new 360-degree freedom of movement
also allows you a second chance at
enemies that have floated out of your
path in several cases being able to look
directly behind me or above assisted in
my takedown of a boss the area X and VR
is something else entirely it feels like
the natural evolution of res and I have
to imagine this could be how creator
Tetsuya Mizuguchi saw his creation from
the beginning the full sensory immersion
elicits a sensation beyond the simple
toe tapping and head bobbing that comes
from playing the original res res
infinite area X in VR engages your
entire body thumbing your synapses in
time with the music and forcing you to
move I felt connected to my tiny being
on screen doling out a symphony with
fireworks in my wake
despite its short campaign you can
complete everything in a little more
than an hour if you're skilled risk
infinite is the game to buy a psvr for
it's hypnotic and enveloping and it's
transformative both within itself and in
the wider scheme of the experience is
made possible by VR you don't want to
sleep on res infinite because of the
addition of more polished visual flair
and the dreamy area X we have a new
classic for the new generation on our
hands